well it's been a while since this man
was uh on this program we're thrilled to
have him back here
the neighborhood airs mondays on cbs at
eight eastern time he's out there with
said the entertainer every single
episode on monday nights and he's got a
new book out where all books are going
to be sold next week november 9th
a hilarious picture book for every kid
who thinks they don't want to read books
or like to read books it's called i
don't want to read this book
written by
max greenfield who's back here on the
rich eisen show on the mercedes-benz van
phone line how are you sir
rich how are you phil i'm good
everything good in your world sir
anything good
i mean couldn't be better i guess okay
well uh because i recall the last time
you were on this program you professed a
fandom of the new york football giants
and we saw them last night not perform
um what's the word for it well
um oh so we had an applicable separation
[Laughter]
so that means the giants are aware of
your separation and they uh they agreed
it should remain amicable so the giants
were involved in this is what you're
saying max as far as you know and yeah
sure
yeah yeah
when did this uh breakup happen
when did it happen max uh it's been a
slow burn uh and not to say that we
can't come back from it but i've
i have not i have not agreed with a lot
of the decisions
that management has made and
once and i and once odell left i knew
things were
going downhill and and i i never got it
back and then finally i was just like
you know what i think we should live in
separate houses
are you happier because of it are you
like a totally you're feeling like a
better person like today you you yeah
you don't miss the misery on a day like
that yeah
yes yes
yes
it was two wonderful super bowl rings i
love them and i remember the happy times
i remember the happy time and what were
those those happy times involved eli
manning or how far back yeah
and
strahan and plexigo
uh a wonderful running game brandon
jacobs
brandon jacobs what a great odell yeah
you know cat just catching balls with
one hand
the best
okay so who's taking up the void in your
sports life since you've had an amicable
breakup with the new york giants
max new york knicks
okay
all right now um i didn't see you in
that video after uh the season opening
championship win
um where everybody went out right in
front of penn plaza and celebrated like
they had just won it all i didn't see
you were you in that video did i miss
that one max
did i miss that one no but i watched
that video a lot
this is great
it was uh it was it was fascinating but
hey man this is this is a fun team all
of a sudden i would i it's a really it's
a really fun team
i think
we have we have a nice mix
which i don't know that a lot of teams
have
some vet
and young guys
a lot of teams are really young
and then you have a lot of teams that
are
old and we sort of split the difference
a little bit and have a nice mixture
right it just i i still just can't get
over julius randle wearing bernard
king's number but that's just me uh i'm
i it's
it
but he wears it very well and his story
and what he's become is truly uh
remarkable so um
what how how when was the last time you
went to the garden did you go this year
have you been there
no yes i've been having it for
a couple years now since right
since the world war
right i bet so okay i'm just i'm i'm
glad for you and all the other nick fans
they'd look to be
really good in a team to root for with a
coach who knows what he's doing and
they're
i i think it all looks good for you yeah
it's it's a really it's a hard team to
dislike it really is
um and then if you're a new yorker and
you've always and look to be fair i'm
not like our friend jerry ferrara who's
like running to the games when they were
terrible and was like you know i think i
think we got
i think we've got a punches shot here at
like you know
at the eighth seed and i'm like
jerry i can't i can't i can't man i know
uh i was not committed when
when times were really tough and i want
to be clear and honest with you about
that
well i'm out in the same way that you
had an amicable relationship with the
giants i had a nasty divorce with the
new york knickerbockers sir it was a
terrible really yes oh yeah absolutely
to to see charles oakley dragged out of
the garden like that and have dolan not
lift a finger and not even put down a
styrofoam cup of coffee it couldn't even
be bothered to in the heat of the moment
in front of everybody just to get up and
stop it from happening because i know
but did you see the ascendant
just flying up and down the floor no i'm
last year i i was conflicted because the
knicks were looking so good and
obviously rj barrett you know quickly
rj's got 35 the other night dude quickly
is it and they're making good basketball
decisions and and i like their coach
their coach is a grinder and i like them
i like them a hell of a lot so
if they can figure out the last three
minutes of the game
[Laughter]
they're they're they they're a lot
they're a team you don't want to play in
the playoffs yeah i like it i like it so
what do we got to do here so
around the 44 minute mark just got to
start focusing just got to lock it down
i i i'm not smart enough um yeah i don't
have i don't have i don't have the
basketball mind
but you're gonna do it i love it uh i
don't know what to do but you know i i
think they have
i think they can figure it out it's not
one of those things you're like i don't
know what to do
where you are you really feel stuck and
goes you have a lot of pieces here you
just gotta figure out how to play those
left corners
it's a good reason max greenfield
that you're you're not the coach of the
knicks or a basketball guy but instead
an actor who's got a neat book out that
i
m my kids do like to read
but uh i i think they love books that
just seem this seems like something that
would be right up their alley i don't
want to read this book available where
wherever books uh are acquired coming
out on november 9th uh how old are your
kids and what what caused you to want to
write something like this max we have an
11 year old girl and a six-year-old boy
um
they are not fans of reading uh nor
was i as a child right
and this speaks to my experience as not
only a parent but my experience as a
young reader and perhaps maybe even an
adult reader right
it is
i someone came to me with the idea of
potentially writing a children's book
and i said well if i was going to do
that
it would be
i would call it i don't want to read
this book it would be all the reasons
why my kids don't like to read books
because i spend a half an hour every
night in their room going hey well what
book should we read before we go to bed
and you'll go through all the books that
are either like we bought because we
thought they were cool or they bought
because they liked the cover or somebody
gave us and they still don't want to
read any of them and they spend
all this time fighting over
well which book are we going to read and
by the time you're done with the fight
you're like well now we got to go to bed
you need to read a book right so this
was what if we put that argument into a
book and that was the book that you read
so it's you know
i don't want to read this book why i
don't want to read the book you know
because words suck and there's too many
senses
who doesn't lose their kind of thought
when they're reading a paragraph and
start thinking about the knicks and what
they could be doing
so
that's the gist of the book um
and it was a really wonderful experience
writing it and
my kids are really excited about it and
uh
and i'm i couldn't be more proud of it i
love it that's so cool man and that's
that's what it's all about i mean uh
you know i i still read to my
eight-year-old daughter it is one of the
most fun things i do i get to do it's
the end of the night and you know
just anything dr seuss that's normally
my go-to so now i'll just add this into
the mix and it's the greatest thing
it's wonderful i love it yeah it's a fun
one and you know look
a lot it's it's certainly for reluctant
readers but it's also for kids who you
know on on a certain night might just go
you've had a long day and like you don't
want to read or get into like a heavy
story can you just do this when it's
dead that's i love it man and i hope
that it it sells so many books that you
get samuel l jackson to read the x-rated
version of it uh for the audiobook that
would be great
or i can get maybe his beats
that's a good one max
thanks for calling in man i greatly
appreciate it you know good luck with
you with your show
with said the entertainer the
neighborhood congrats on that success
your emmy nomination and so much more we
take credit for it i don't know if
you're aware of that but we do that here
on the show well you deserve it all
thank you very much enjoy the next let's
talk down the line as the season gets
longer appreciate it maybe maybe me and
jerry ferreira will come on there let's
do it
let's do it yes we'll have our own i
would i do that in a heartbeat
so i'm going to hold you too
you should hear
let's do it you want to have
conversation two and a half hour
conversations we have after i don't know
every three games
you know i'm just telling you the things
that are doing right yeah i know it's
it's it's gonna work it's gonna work
it's always up for him it's it's he
thinks everything's the greatest he's
still disappointed that carmelo didn't
work out you know what i mean like
so am i by the way
i know it's the only place that he went
pretty much where it didn't work out
with the exception i guess the nuggets
and it still even worked out there but
hey sometimes you know you you got the
best of plans and and the mojo whatever
was going on it's changed for new york
so enjoy the next season we'll chat soon
i appreciate it you got it that's max
greenfield check him out at i am
greenfield on twitter check out i don't
want to read this book available where
all books are sold next week the
neighborhood on cbs at eight eastern
time in pacific
starring max greenfield and cedric the
entertainer hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here